there's almost nothing worth saying
about Street Fighter The Legend of
chun-li it barely even manages to
register is so bad it's fun because so
much of it is just boring so why bother
talking about it
well because it's a massive failure of
intent this feels like an honest attempt
to taking the video game adaptation and
elevating it to the same level of
respect as literary adaptations but they
failed ok how do I justify saying that
they were trying to make an arti drama
and not just some action schlock editing
in camerawork these days most garbage
films that are cranked out with a little
regard to actual quality are shot in 16
by 9 aspect ratio because that's the
same aspect ratio as an HDTV and the
stupid people who buy garbage movies out
of the bargain bin of Walmart are more
interested in using every square
centimeter of their 50-inch television
than they are in seeing interesting
cinematography these people aren't that
bright and they get distracted by the
black bars of the top and bottom of the
screen that frame of film that was
originally shot in an aspect ratio wider
than their TV screen also it makes work
flow easier if you know that your movie
is doomed to live out its life is a
permanent member of the discount bin and
late-night cable TV then you save
yourself the trouble and shoot for home
video it saves everyone time and money
so HD TVs are 16:9 this ratio is also
written out as one point seven seven
eight to one The Legend of chun-li is
shot in the much much wider
2.38 9 to 1 ratio this isn't necessarily
a judgment aspect ratio is just a tool
and isn't inherently good or bad but it
means that someone in the film was
spending a lot more time thinking about
their job than anyone else was it also
speaks to tone action movies tend to use
narrower aspect ratios because it allows
for more vertical space in a screen area
for things like jump kicks and
explosions characters on screen are
closer together but you can put some
distance between them without cutting
off the top and bottom of the face
making the characters more human and
likeable wider aspect ratios are usually
used when the cinematographer wants to
fit in lots of beautiful scenery or
because they want to put lots of
distance between characters and isolate
them a close-up in a really wide aspect
will cut off
most all of the characters face making
them less human and more mysterious this
probably seems like a really irrelevant
point to be making but it's significant
because choices like aspect-ratio are
used to code the mental state that the
audience should be in super wide aspect
ratios are associated with Artie
camerawork on some level this project
started off as Crouching Tiger they
wanted chun-li to be a martial arts
action movie that was at its core a
character driven drama much like
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon it's not a
bad goal all told and a character like
chun-li isn't a bad choice if that's the
story you want to tell within the Street
Fighter universe shuttle II is easily
one of the more accessible characters
she's an attractive martial artist who
works for Interpol she's out to avenge
her father's death and that's about it
unlike a lot of other characters from
the games you don't have to expose it a
deep mythology explained magic powers or
introduced dozens of other core
characters in order to tell her basic
story it's a straightforward origins and
revenge plot that audiences are familiar
with which frees you up to really focus
on character and story the second cue is
the editing the movie starts with a
glory shot of the Golden Gate Bridge
which pans over to kid chun-li playing
piano and her father watching proudly
will adult chun-li narrates overtop
ruminating on her childhood dream of
being a concert pianist this bit lasts
almost a minute and has only two edits
for a very quick insert this cuts into a
much faster paced sequence of aerial
shots of Hong Kong and the music changes
from relaxed piano too tense electro
rock
the editor and cinematographer are
working to bring us into Chumley's
emotional space they want us to share
her viewpoint and understand the
contrast in her life the peace and
serenity of her early years in San
Francisco versus the uncertainty and
chaos of Hong Kong this is acceptable
filmmaking but it still sucks because
the script is fecking terrible that's
what went wrong with Crouching Tiger
Hidden Street Fighter the script sucks
balls and Kristin Kreuk can't narrate
her way out of a paper bag of course
it's hard to stay interested in your
voiceover script when it consists of
gems like this
my father was an important businessman
she sounds like she's reading a bedtime
story to a three-year-old it's not the
least of the scripts problems though for
some brevity let's just make it into
list of major flaws though I'm not going
to be able to get to all of these in
detail one terrible dialogue two
villains with unclear goals and
motivations three poorly explained
stakes or multiple extraneous characters
with dead end plot lines five main
character learns nothing worthwhile and
does not change six changes are made to
the source material that actively make
the story worse seven inconsistent moral
core in a movie about doing the right
thing and this is the bottom line this
movie sucks
because the script is terrible with all
that in mind here's a spoiler if ik plot
rundown Chumlee who wants to be a
concert pianist her family moves to Hong
Kong
she is taught wushu by her father her
father is kidnapped by Neal McDonough
who's playing bison but he looks and
acts nothing like bison and that name
sounds stupid anyway so we're going to
call him neal mcdonough she becomes a
concert pianist she gets an ancient
scroll as a gift she sees a man with a
gang tat get mugged in the subway her
mom dies of cancer neal mcdonough has
his business partners killed for no
discernible reason neal mcdonough acts
menacing chun-li disrespects her mother
by giving her a Buddhist funeral dressed
in black she gets her scroll read or
something and I guess becomes homeless
in Thailand because the guy with the
gang tat who was also sweeping the
street is apparently Yoda this isn't
well explained at all and none of her
friends or family seemed concerned that
she's quitting her job in moving to
Bangkok on a whim sure
following the death of her mother
without making any prior arrangements
for housing finances or contact man will
come back to this plot point later neal
mcdonough acts menacing while talking
about real estate chun-li fights off six
guys while starving and sleep-deprived
then collapses after murdering a man
seriously he can barely get up and she
goes out of her way to tip a shelving
unit full of tools onto the guide even
if he's not dead he's never gonna walk
straight again she's picked up by the
guy with a gang tat who trains her to
make fireballs in an extended training
montage there's a good 20 minutes here
following a real estate conspiracy
subplot that ends with a chick fight in
a bathroom at a nightclub then never
comes up again but she learns something
about the white rose and a shipping
manifest chun-li shoots a man in the
chest at point-blank range neal
mcdonough acts menacing while punching a
dead body Jen tells chun-li that Neal
McDonough used to just steal fish but
got rich then he went all dexter in the
head and killed his wife in order to put
all his goodness into his baby so that
he wouldn't have a conscience it would
only be pure evil we'll come back to
this one - the evil guys attacked the
secret hideout in the stupidest way
possible by sending in ninjas to fight
hand-to-hand when they have a rocket
launcher in the car both parts of that
sentence are stupid but it does give us
the best line in the film forget it on
Jimmy there
I'll do it myself in the explosion gang
dies but not really neal mcdonough acts
menacing vega attacks chun-li and gets
his ass kicked
chun-li physically assaults a civilian
for not giving a private shipping
manifests she gets trapped and captured
neal mcdonough kills her dad in front of
her she escapes but takes a grazing shot
in the market the crowd starts throwing
fruit and goons decide that it's not
worth taking another shot at the prone
girl twenty feet away
again uses magic powers to heal her
bullet wound in seconds and she figures
out how to make a fireball she threatens
to assault the dockworker again there's
a big fight at the docks again fights
the black dude they figure out that the
white roses nail McDonough's daughter
chun-li knocks neal mcdonough off the
roof of the fire ball breaks his neck
buries her dad plant some sequel bait
credits roll such a load of crap did you
even notice the two main characters that
I cut from the plot these two the
Interpol agent and the Thai detective
nope guess we didn't need them let's
start with the whole abandoning your
past life storyline the first major flaw
in this is that no one tries to stop her
her mother just died she's clearly in a
deeply vulnerable place in her life and
not one of these people friends or
extended family tries to intervene when
she quits her job and packs up her house
and that brings up another issue she
doesn't actually abandon everything like
Ken asked her to she doesn't get up and
walk away from it all taking only some
bare essentials and living with the
poorest of society oh sure she sleeps in
an alley and skips out on showering for
a few days but at the end of the movie
she's moving right back into her
multi-million dollar Hong Kong mansion
sure living on the streets for a couple
weeks was probably instructive but she
was basically a poverty tourist if she
ever got tired of living in a slum there
was always a mansion waiting back in
hong kong this ties directly into the
character arc chun-li doesn't really
learn anything or change at the start of
the film she's a confident spunky kind
hearted person as the film progresses
she dabbles in poverty tourism kills
three men in cold blood without remorse
and returns to her life of wealth as a
spunky kind-hearted slightly more
confident person now that's not an
irredeemable problem lots of good action
movies have main characters who don't
learn or change all that much but it is
is a problem when your movie opens with
the main character pondering how they
turned into the person they are
sometimes I wonder how I got to be the
way I am the writers have explicitly set
up a transformation story I used to be a
little girl who wanted to be a piano
player now I'm a cold-hearted killer who
murders people for the greater good or I
used to be a selfish upper-class snob
but I learned the value of hard work
community and sacrificed something
anything any transformation contrast is
deeply compromised by the early scene
where her father is kidnapped were shown
that she's been exposed to this criminal
world since she was a little girl and we
only spend the briefest time with her as
a civilian because it's such a tiny part
of the opening her time as a concert
pianist looks more like a brief
interlude in a life of violence a hobby
rather than a normal world that she's
pulled out of and what little we see of
her in that stage of her life is
basically the same person we see at the
end the only thing that changes is the
number of living parents and felony
murders next up is the whole thing where
Neal McDonough transfers his goodness
into a little baby I have a couple
problems with this scene first and least
important is that the intensity and
violence of the scene is considerably
out of place given the tone treatment of
violence throughout the rest of the film
it's an extremely jarring kick the dog
scene that's meant to show the audience
just how evil the bad guy is but I think
it becomes less effective because it's
too jarring it's such a sharp break from
almost everything else that it pulls you
out to a place where it stops being the
actions of a character and becomes the
decisions of some filmmakers the only
other scene that comes close as where
McDonough is using the politician lady
as a punching bag everything else is
sanitized bloodless pg-13 fantasy
violence beyond that is the implications
of this scene on the metaphysical world
of the film it's one thing for this myth
to exist forget to tell Chumlee this
mystical rumor that he heard but it's
effectively confirmed later in the film
that his daughter is in fact the vessel
holding all of the goodness of his soul
that means that in the world of
streetfighter good and bad are tangible
products that can be transferred from
one person to another the implications
on freewill and morality are staggering
but most importantly it does nothing to
actually improve the story at all the
entire problem I have with this is that
it creates a really inconsistent moral
Center for the movie you see the movie
basically turns poverty into a privilege
rather than bison growing up to be who
he is because of socio-economic
pressures it's just black magic he
didn't get caught up in gang warfare and
drugs and violence and slowly
desensitized to the lives of other
people it was just black magic instead
of making the bad guy evil it just makes
him weird we still have no idea what
he's up to what he's doing on a day to
day basis and what his end goal is he
has his co-conspirators murdered but at
the time I honestly thought they were
the legitimate board of directors of his
company making the whole ordeal kind of
stupid well even if they are criminals
it's still a stupid idea
gangs don't operate like a chess board
you don't win just because you killed
the king not that it matters one way or
the other since we have no idea what
they're actually up to drugs human
trafficking murder for hire no clue
there's a plot in here about buying up
waterfront property for redevelopment
but they're extorting the city board
into making the sale which makes no
sense was the board zoning the area's a
slum for purely altruistic reasons it's
like the writers couldn't decide if
bison should be using black magic
private military shady business
practices or a Chinatown style
conspiracy so they tried to squeeze them
all in it's hard to care about any of
them since the stakes are so low the
people get kicked out of the slum then
vanished never to be seen or mentioned
again the big showdown at the end with
Interpol bison and chun-li doesn't even
have anything to do with the whole slum
buyout anyway and the plot line is never
resolved last point before we wrap up
the changes to the source material
actively make the story worse in her
original incarnations chun-li is
alternately an undercover cop or an
Interpol agent changing her from a cop
to a concert pianist does nothing to
raise the stakes or make the character
more relatable in fact it makes the
story harder to tell because now you
to justify all kinds of crazy crap
that's super easy to hand wave if she
works for Interpol why is she in
Thailand
she works for Interpol why does she know
insane martial arts
she works for Interpol why does she have
combat training and not freaked out the
first time someone pulls a gun on her
she works for Interpol why does she care
about the legal front of a criminal
organization buying out riverfront slums
she works for Interpol the character
conflict comes baked in when she
confronts bison does she stick with her
training let the courts bring him to
justice
or does she extract revenge and kill him
herself when she meets again does she
stick with Interpol with its superior
resources at the cost of rules and
expectations or become a vigilante and
join the order of the web instead we're
asked to believe that concert pianist
who learned kung-fu as a kid is going to
be willing to throw herself at a
well-armed international criminal
organization and not wind up as a Jane
Doe floating facedown in the river so
they wanted to legitimize the video game
adaptation and they screwed it up
royally with a god-awful script every
single problem with this movie comes
back to the script the characters
frequently make decisions based on
information they don't have because the
script needs to get them somewhere the
villains are a chocolate pudding made of
every bad guy trope possible resulting
in antagonist that's too confusing to
take seriously and entire chunks of the
film are flat-out useless to the story
as if that wasn't enough it's also too
boring to laugh at there's some gem
moments ripe with camp value but the
tone is too serious for the stupid
script and the script is too stupid for
the serious tone
so that's Legend of chun-li take it or
leave it
next week we go back to the guys who
brought us cranked to with gamer that uh
gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha
skin
you